yeah it it sounds like science fiction
at really how much respect have we to
give you for this how close do you
believe you are to being able to do this
look in the course of science history
impossible quotes just popped out all
along the way by so-called experts and
that we all know that for instance in
1903 the Wright brothers just flew their
first plane when every every single
scientist at the time believed that that
was totally impossible
so I don't believe the word impossible
I've been just working at this project
for the past thirty years and I think
that's a huge time I just been working
at through all possible stumbling blocks
and I just made the announcement to when
I was a pretty sure that it can be
carried out right now we have the
technology we have the technology so you
say right so we're going to talk people
through how you see this being done
bring us bring us through the detail
surgeon well this is how we understand
the procedure will work I'm sure you're
correct uh sir if we get any points
wrong but we're just going to look at
this graphic here to explain it to
people at home the patient's head and
the donors body are going to be cool to
extend the time their cells can survive
without oxygen the tissue around the
neck is then dissected and the major
blood vessels linked before the spinal
cords are cut the patient's head would
then be moved on to their new body and
the two ends of the spinal cord fused
together using a chemical called
polyethylene blue coal as a type of glue
the patient would then be kept in a coma
for three to four weeks to help mesh the
body parts together with electrodes
fitted to help stimulate the spinal cord
to strengthen new nerve connections